welcome to this video when playing a
beautiful mind from Switzerland went for
the Slav let's see okay let's go for
this for the SH Lester variation
currently doing a video serious on the
ISS see about the Slav and this is one
of the lines that I had recommended yeah
a six so quite interesting the idea to
play b5 but after a for this some
response a six a five is very very solid
like make sure that the Queen side is
not fluid anymore what has a hard time
to improve this pieces here
should I go over there on your wind okay
so is this a position well well I don't
know but I'd like to do something where
I can play a fibers I wanted to say
someone okay he's intending him before
hmm yeah this is very very crude okay
come on let's uh let's see
yeah should I take hmm I don't know
if I take on f2 he needs to take with
the king hmm this no direct refutation
still maybe bring this pressure on the
FO will would do something
or this this I don't mind so much I
wonder if I can play you five now you
find why it looks risky but I don't see
at the moment what shouldn't be
shouldn't be working if he takes with
the pawn I take Quincy five we take okay
taking with the night I can take her to
which she simply ignored isn't this good
I mean hard to believe it shouldn't be
good
Bishop takes Queen takes the question is
some what exactly is my next move if
everything else fails I play queen
Knight to c3 but okay he just just
returned with the night which I didn't
really I didn't really see
can you believe that what am i doing now
hmm
curious
yeah the moccasin trapped
hmm
yeah we should have to have Knight c3
but it's not the smooth is not
threatening anything okay it's an
exchange like anyway what we get what a
weird motif just retreats and trap said
check
again he's trying to trap it
well
yeah don't even have a tricky black
resigns yeah this is all very very
difficult to believe after 95 let's
let's check this I mean I cannot believe
that this would be good for white yeah
okay I can take any file of course but
this is really bad head is bad
so this means I should probably do
something like this year then they take
here maybe yeah this is a poem and it
isn't the porn okay yeah that's also not
yeah this is really curious and a man
must adhere the best move according to
compass would be to and this is check
this is just not working
yeah very very weird and that's yeah
maybe was this one yeah something like
that
this could be em could be there could be
an interesting way to play something
like this is actually quite good check
check this war would be a draw at the
end of the Queen here well yeah probably
it was about equal or something but yeah
I lost I lost my way 95 93 amazing
thanks for watching